Well, we know the rate has to be the distance divided by the time. An easy way
to think about it is just a rate, like miles per hour. We know miles is a
distance, per, which means we'll use division, an hour, which is time. If we
want to solve using algebra, we'll take this equation and we'll divide both
sides By the variable t. This will isolate the r. So we know the rate is
distance divided by time. If we want to solve for time, then instead of
dividing both sides by t, let's divide both sides by r. When we divide this
side by r and this side by r, we'll get d divided by r is equal to 1 t. So we
know the amount of time an object traveled would be its distance traveled
divided by its rate.